في حلقه امبارح استعرضنا سواء ابرز كلمات
وعبارات سيطرت على الاخبار هاي السنه
واليوم وما اقتربنا من نهايه العام خلونا
نستعرض سوى مجموعه من الارقام القياسيه
اللي سجلت في 2022 اولها طبعا واللي ما في
حدا مش ملاحظ طبعا الي كمان ما في حدا
بالعالم مش متاثر فيه كمان هو التضخم
وارتفاع الاسعار الجنوني والصاروخي في
العالم وخصوصا في اسعار المواد الغذائيه
واللي طبعا من اسباب الرئيسيه كانت الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه اما الرقم القياسي
الثاني فكان ايضا من النتائج الحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه وهو ارتفاع عدد
اللاجئين ست مليون طلعوا من اوكرانيا لدول
الجوار وثمانيه مليون نجحوا في الداخل
الاوكراني لتتجاوز بذلك اعداد اللاجئين
على الصعيد العالمي حاجز ال 100 مليون
وهذا رقم قياسي سجل في عام 2022
ومن حرب روسيا واوكرانيا التغير المناخي
اول رقم قياسي هاي السنه في هذا المجال مش
غريب علينا طبعا وصلنا متعودين انه كل سنه
بنسمعه هو نفسه عم نحكي طبعا عن الصيف
الاكثر حراره ما بعرفش لايمتى لوين ممكن
يوصل يعني مع الحراره ولكن مع الحراره
العاليه طبعا زادت الحرائق مع العالم في
العالم والسنه كمان غطت اكثر من 600 الف
هكتار حول العالم عم نحكي عن سته الاف
كيلومتر مربع
كوريا الشماليه وصواريخها كانت كمان من
الارقام القياسيه هذه السنه وتحديدا في
نوفمبر وتحديدا كمان لما اطلقت خلال 24
ساعه 23 صاروخ في بحر اليابان ردا على
اوسع منى وراه جويه ما بين كوريا الجنوبيه
وامريكا ومن كوريا لبريطانيا وجنازه
الملكه اليزابيث ولا اعداد من حضروا فيها
للقاء نظره الوداع الاخيره عليها في كنيسه
واسمستر بحيث انه هذه الارقام تجاوزت
250.000 شخص وهذا رقم قياسي اخر هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
ومتى المتصدر العناوين والاخبار طوال هذه
السنه ونكمل كمان الى الماسك اله نصيب من
الارقام القياسيه لاكثر من سبب الاول انه
هو الاغنى في العالم والثاني بسبب صفقه
تويتر اللي بلغت قيمتها 44 مليار دولار
وثالث هو سلسله الاقالات اللي شغال فيها
العالم وغيرها وغيرها طبعا عفوا من
القرارات والتحركات غير المسبوقه اما على
الصعيد الفني فمجموعه فنيه كان بيملكه
الراحل اعلن احد مؤسسي مايكروسوفت حققت
رقم قياسي لما به لما بيعت في مزاد مقابل
مليار و620$
فنيا كمان النجمه تصدرت الارقام القياسيه
في جانبين واحد ايجابي والثاني للاسف سلبي
فاولا البومها مد نايتس اللي حصل على رقم
قياسي اكثر البوم من صنع خلال يوم واحد
عبر منفاعي اما السلبي فهو حصول على لقب
المشهور الاكثر تلوثا للبيئه والسبب طبعا
رحلتها الجويه الكتيره في طائره الخاصه
وفي عالم الرياضه الاسباني
22 22 بيفوزوا في فرنسا المفتوحه
والبرنسلام هي البطولات الاربعه الكبرى في
التنس واخيرا الارقام اهم الارقام
القياسيه في 2022 كان ببساطه الثمن
الثمانيه مليار وهو تعداد سكان العالم
اللي تجاوزه هاي العتبه الشهر الماضي
[موسيقى]